you look fantastic people i see you
putting them thirst traps out there all
right
oh my god crapping
listen i don't even have a quarantine
bag but three months later
congratulations are in order
nic nash has officially tied the knot
with musician
jessica betts et can confirm this is our
place
okay this is our crew
i'ma take care of you the claws actress
broke the news via instagram on monday
posting a gorgeous photo from the
couple's august 29th wedding with the
caption
mrs carol denise betts at jessica betts
music
love wins
[Music]
[Applause]
and the 50 year old kept the love coming
posting her leading ladies song
catch me on her stories as well as this
photo of the happy couple with the
hashtag
plot twist i'm just discovering things
so are we neither nesi nor jessica has
spoken publicly about their relationship
but it appears they date back to at
least 2011
when the singer-songwriter reportedly
performed at mises malibu wedding to jay
tucker
i couldn't be happier i'm a proud friend
that's first game notoriety in 2000 when
her song getup
was featured on the big mama's house
soundtrack she went on to win
road to stardom five years later jessica
betts
is an artist that feeds your soul
get into it i love you jessica
in june 2018 betts joined nash on the
set of claws
performing one of her songs on the
episode where nisi's character
gets married when you get to hang out on
set with your home
girl and things got steamy in february
when vets shared this
topless photo of nash in honor of her
birthday
along with the caption happy birthday to
the real one
you know everybody has a turn everybody
has a season
and it just so happened for me mine was
greater later
this marks nash's third marriage the mrs
america star was previously married to
don nash from 1994
until 2007. she remarried jay tucker in
2011
only to file for divorce last december
two months after the two had called it
quits
the month prior nash spoke with e.t
about how
she and tucker were able to remain
amicable despite their split
for us it's easy because we love each
other
the love is just taken on a different
form but that's always going to be my
friend
always the actress also made it clear
she had no intention of rejoining
the dating world any time soon is it too
early to ask are you ready to date again
what is this foolishness you speak of
you see come on now no wait girl i'm
just over here drinking my water and
healing
hmm no no i ain't ready to put all this
back on the block
too much too soon